humber valdez and he makes his season
debut for the astros after fracturing
his left ring finger
in spring training with his first start
that was also on his pitching hand
fastball curveball and
change up tommy pam a lead off walk has
stolen six bases
as has manny machado who's the d.h
nice pitch robert valdez strikes out
manny machado gets his first strikeout
since coming back
off the il his first k of 2021 another
jake j cronin worth bats here
grounds slowly towards altuve it will be
a tough turn
good flip and correa makes it happen
altuve to correa to guriel play was
challenged by the padres and the call
overturned as chronower is safe at first
base
he reaches on the fielder's choice and
here's fernando tatis jr
and he hits this one to right playable
for kyle tucker
nelson lumet on the hill tonight for the
padres first to career appearance
against the astros he's making his first
start the last two outings have been out
of the bullpen
in that piggyback situation with ryan
weathers
now with 20 games in 20 days they've
gone to a six-man rotation
you see the struggles too for bregman
it's been with two outs of runners in
scoring position
on the ground and the second baseman
jake cronenworth who takes care of
business and wraps up the first inning
but nonetheless in his career haas at 3
41 hitter
against the astros lefty the lefty right
here into hosmer
is one of those guys that doesn't like
wearing that elbow guard
right off that tricep area the other way
against
profar much weaker hitter right handed
swing and a miss
he gets jerks in profile picks up his
second strikeout
so runners at the corners and two outs
for haciend kim
swing and a miss got him with the
breaking ball
robert valdez picks up two strikeouts in
the inning on the curve
eric hosmer has left this game after
being hit by a pitch last inning
second and third mccormick at third
straw at second
two down here in the second swing and a
miss that was a slider
that is strike three and the second k of
the inning for lumet
he works into the third inning and it is
the top of the padres order tommy pham
leading it off for san diego
in the air to right field tucker going
back at the wall that ball is gone
home run for tommy pham his third of the
year
and the padres strike first on top one
to nothing
swing at the curveball or swing at the
fastball hit the fastball
that's exactly what tommy pham does what
a picture perfect swing
loads up and delivers the punch two outs
two on
myers of the batter rocket through the
middle altuve's gonna race to the bag he
beats mateo
who is flying to second jose altuve a
great defensive play
on a bullet up the middle by will meyer
jltube
coming up mlb active leaders highest
career batting average a 311 hitter
swinging a miss and altuve strikes out
that is a third strikeout for lumet
first out here in the third inning
two on now with two outs for the astros
big situation here for lumet to center
and mateo makes the catch and lumet
out of danger in the third inning can
finish off this inning well
if he goes four innings of two hit one
run baseball he and the astros will be
very pleased with that
called third strike fromber valdez
welcome back
his first start of 2021 right here in a
3-2 count put the handcuffs on kim and
locked him up
probably on a very similar pitch count
as from valdez prom are able to get
through
four innings in 72 pitches lumets at 63
right now
this one's driven good one to left it's
gone
astros up two to one on mccormick's
fourth home run
chessy fizz laid into that one
don't look at batting average when it
comes to chas mccormick look at
production numbers
nine hits on the year four of them home
runs
15 runs batted in and 11 runs scored and
now christian javier
works out of the pen with a two to one
lead tried to hold up on the slider he
goes around machado down on strikes
javier picks up his first strikeout see
if they move the runner here he's on the
move this ball into center field
long run for straw still on the move and
he's going to make the catch over his
shoulder
bam's going to have to retreat he'll get
back in time
but straw making a nice running catch to
retire kronerworth for out number two
so two out and fam at first for fernando
tatis jr who is over two
and a miss javier got him with a fast
ball strikes out
two and his first hitting out of the
bullpen kyle tucker
leading it off here in the bottom of the
fifth inning good pitch
and he strikes him out so tucker retired
for the first time in this game ramirez
goes with the little cutter
getting him with the two strikes
right side and diving is cronenworth
from one knee makes the play
jake cronenworth continuing to play
outstanding defense
what's amazing is you can see that ball
just extended even more for cronenworth
he peaks at alex bregman
knows he doesn't have the force out at
second and takes the easy out at first
minute second correa at first two outs
in the fifth
swing and a miss and ramirez able to
strike out mccormick down the inning
got to bring up hostile kim their third
baseman who struck out twice
the blazer there it is strike three on
the fastball
and it's another punch out for javier
his third
and there's one away so that's three
strikeouts for christian
and one out in the seventh inning now
facing the top of the order tommy pham
this ball hit high to
center field straight away straw all the
way back he's on the warning
track and he puts it away bam hit it
about 400 feet but he is out number two
here's manny machado who struck out
against javier last time they matched up
bow tip cut by maldonado big strikeout
for christian javier
as he gets manny machado for the second
straight time
let's see if correa can pick up a big
rbi here bottom of the seventh of a one
run game
and they are going to walk correa
intentionally for the second straight
time
tingler is going to go after chaz
mccormick here
fly ball right field myers
back to the wall to make the catch
at the top of the wall wow inches from
being gone
myers makes the catch just above the
yellow line in right field
one down here in the eighth end it
brings up fernando
this one is driven a deep left field for
fernando
it's up and gone a blast to left for
tatis his 14th of the year
and the padres tied up two to two a
blast to left for tatis
continued fight with this club and
answering back
see the high slider he knew it right off
the bat
oh yeah spin it and pressly will face
the eight nine and one hitters
swing and a miss down goes revos and
that's a strikeout on three pitches for
ryan presley
pitch and kim lifts this one to
left to his right mccormick backing up
couple of steps shy of the warning track
and he makes the catch 1-0
ground ball left side waiting on it
correa shortstop scoops it up and throws
to first
a one two three inning for ryan presley
here's alex bregman
swing and a miss he struck him out we're
headed for bonus baseball again
this time the fan takes his spot at
second base and machado
is over three in this game of the walkie
struck out three time
line to right field down the line it's a
fair ball into the right field corner
tomic pham is coming around the padres
will score throw goes to second and
machado
is safe padres take a 3-2 lead in the
10th inning
so double an intentional walk and now
another walk
and jerickson profile will bat there's a
fly ball hit pretty well but playable
tucker and straw converge straw carls
them off
and miles makes the play before
mcfadding with one out and runners at
first and third
there's a line drive to right field
bregman will tag up
here comes the throw by will myers
bregman will be
safe for tied at three bregman scores
the tying run on that line drive sac
fly by chaz mccormick three to three
and it loads the bases against altuve
altuve hits it in the air to center
field mateo is out there waiting
and he makes the catch sending us to the
11th inning
first in third nobody out and ha kim
this one is blooped to right field and
falling fast it's in for a hit in from
third base comes profar
and the padres take a 4-3 lead first and
third
a run in and tommy pham line to right
field and a base hit
[Applause]
on the ground and through into right
field a base hit
kim coming in from third base he'll
score machado to third
and the padres take a 6-3 lead padres
taking an 8-3 lead
jericho coming up now it's a ground ball
through into center field from third
base one run is in here comes another
run and two more for the padres makes it
10-3
they have broken this one wide open in
houston